[Music]
people on social media are cringing
after seeing a trailer for a new
animated film
upon hearing the new voice of pinocchio
okay who's voice in pinocchio i hope
it's gilbert godfrey he'd be good samuel
l jackson oh he'd be great
oh yeah so by the way let me tell you
now it's it's not a joke this is like
really the this is it chris
cares about pratt
i don't believe my eyes your name will
be pinocchio
father when can i leave to be on my own
i've got the whole world to see you is
right no we gotta guess it
father when can i leave to be on my own
i've got the whole world to see you are
jews
is it because he's like gay it kind of
sounds like polly's short huh it sounds
like a gay
straight
polly
my tongue
it's a gay polly shore
wow how did polly shore land pinocchio
yeah how are you
that's so that's so odd for an animated
character that is so strange and it's
crazy
pinocchio's not made by disney it's a
lion's gate pinocchio it can be made by
anybody there's like so for context this
year or the year that that's coming out
that's only one of three pinocchio
movies coming out made by different
companies no way there's a lion's gate
dude the pinocchio craze this one's
going it's just getting hot let's make a
pinocchio why don't we make a [ __ ]
pie i mean this is going this one's
going straight to streaming and dvd or
whatever and then there's another one
netflix is gonna have with guillermo del
toro
uh
yeah it is and then disney's gonna have
their own which is a live action one not
animated but this animated one with all
with poly short is poly shorts they
should all have pog shore they should
all have polish that would be really
good you think they should all have fun
i think you should play every character
as well in all the movies i'm glad he's
getting something the weird thing is i
don't understand like who's is this for
us is this for like our generation
because like
what i don't even know what kids want
who's doing this
lions gate are they like we need to have
gay characters well i don't that's the
thing is i don't think he's supposed to
be gay that's just how polly short his
character yeah it just sounds like a
surfer pothead
but only we know that that's the weird
thing it's like we know it because we
know where that's coming from from
paulie shore movies it kind of sounds
like an exaggerated version of polly's
shore is it isn't pinocchio a boy
yeah
yeah that's true interesting right is it
a comedy though no it's though the whole
trailer just seems like a normal
pinocchio movie i mean it's probably
comedy in the way that like maybe like
you know is he a boy a real boy now
because it didn't look like a wood boy
he's a wood boy i believe oh he's
definitely wood boy what are you talking
about which one's geppetto i didn't see
japan japan was the one who was talking
to him the other one looks like i was
dumb oh dumbledore
oh that's not the same geppetto i know
what about [ __ ] jiminy cricket you
guys see that
i don't understand how people like
because like the comments on it are
mostly people have never heard of
polyshort and they're just like dude the
voice actor sounds like he's not even
trying it sounds like he doesn't want to
be here it honestly does sound weird
what he sounds like yeah exactly but
like that's what i'm like he doesn't
want to be anyone oh my god it's an
interesting choice it's an interesting
choice to have polly sure
yeah it's like a that's what i don't get
is like only a very select generation
would understand the context of his
voice and why i'm from that generation i
don't understand why he's in this
project what they should do you know
what they should do they should take
like triple a like like animated movies
like like whatever the [ __ ] what's
the princess one
frozen
and just cast likes d-list actors and
like you have all the footage already
just [ __ ] have them do their voices
and let's see what the [ __ ] happens so
you think you think they're onto
something with this because i think it's
kind of cool like dubbing it are they on
to something with like having these like
major franchise type character movies be
played by the last person you expect i
rather watch an animation where it's
just voiced over by like
nba basketball players
people that aren't
acting just the worst acting you've ever
heard i'd rather watch that can be as i
want to see uh the guys that dub kung fu
movies
man these guys again i want charles
barkley to dub everything dude charles
barkley is
i don't want him to add that like like
there's a bunch of big women around
from georgia yeah just like
dude every time he talks about big women
i [ __ ] lie i want i want them to do
the girl voices too oh yes i'm in for
that but the rock's got to be in there
too somehow oh yeah and kevin hart kevin
hart why because it's all about pride
it's all about power do you think um you
know how like lately i mean i say lately
but in the past few years whenever like
animated films come out and like the
response is so overwhelmingly bad yeah
like they actually have the power to
change a little bit of it like they did
with sonic yes oh yeah
do you think they'll change anything
about that they just completely take
polish are people pissed oh yeah they
don't [ __ ] understand did they change
the voice actor for sonic they didn't
change but but they changed all the art
of sonic because they thought sonic
looks so stupid they messed his teeth up
right was that what it was they changed
his whole face
they reanimated the whole [ __ ] thing
that's the one with jim carrey right
they pushed it back to i think so then
maybe they could do a few more passes of
[ __ ] voice recording right oh man but
even when you see the trailer it seems
like a parody it doesn't seem like it
belongs that's i agree that's what i
think it does seem like a pretty shitty
straight to streaming version this one
or the sonic the hedgehog this one yeah
the even the animation doesn't look good
who's playing uncle who
who's playing the the geppetto one
uh gepetto john heater he does look like
dumbledore uncle joey from full house
isn't he a country music star or
something that sounds like
anybody's last name kenny yeah
go back home no yo i worked with him
kenny you probably wrote for them
oh never seen him um no i don't know
what he is
talking oh he was oh dude rocco's modern
life oh he's this guy you spongebob
okay wow
okay that's so weird that polly's sure
it's been the whole thing it's so weird
john hater
dude the joke was good though when the
horse was looking the other way and he
hits his head on the branch that was
good oh he is it was even like off by
the beat yeah it was good but so it goes
back to that question that you were
saying right like who who's this for
that's the thing i can't understand
children director dvd dude kids yeah but
like but like spongebob stars the dude
tom kenny he's spongebob's voice yeah so
that's a total difference he should have
been pinocchio there don't you think
that parents nowadays just throw on
netflix and [ __ ] and pick something i
play i feel like they just watch youtube
it's not like a kid's gonna knock me
into he's like is that polly sure
like if you caught tycho watching that
and you didn't know and you just [ __ ]
heard paulie shore would you be like
give me that [ __ ] delete that [ __ ] no
yeah he just watches whatever you want
you watch the movies before to make sure
it's okay for him so on youtube he has
uh youtube kids so it's already
pre-sensor
but then on uh on what is it called like
netflix or apple whatever apple tv we
pick it together what was that weird
[ __ ] that we were watching on on youtube
and then all of a sudden it flipped to
that [ __ ] indian zombie thing where
the kid was all bleeding and [ __ ] and
blurry yeah that's the bad thing jill
was like holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] so
every once in a while we'll let them
watch uh regular youtube
and this kid likes [ __ ] horror [ __ ]
it's weird like we'll watch spider-man
right and then like let's say this
starts to introduce like venom and goes
who's that guy
and then now he just only wants to watch
venom and then now venom there's [ __ ]
carnage which is
and he [ __ ] likes carnage and [ __ ]
i'm like
dude you're a [ __ ] little freak
aren't you dude i love connor if i was a
kid
i love you little freak arches
but i like carnage in the comic yeah
he's [ __ ] four years old he like
likes [ __ ] guts and [ __ ] oh it's
weird man one day you're gonna be like
don't you want to see like spiderman
[ __ ] spiderman [ __ ]
that's carnage [ __ ]
carnage is sick though yeah carnegie
that is weird because my friend's
niece she likes horror movies and she
wanted to be penny wise and she's like
taika's age oh yeah yeah like like your
parents let you [ __ ] watch that [ __ ]
like sometimes crazy [ __ ] will pop up
and oh isn't that scary to you or
whatever he goes no because he doesn't
know the context yeah that's true maybe
apparently it's [ __ ] weird because
it's just like how when you play call of
duty and all of a sudden there's a bunch
of six-year-olds on the server with you
oh you're like how the [ __ ] are you kids
doing this in a [ __ ] mic and they're
killing you every time if there's a kid
on a mic saying the [ __ ] f word to
you on call of duty he's for sure
watching youtube adults
sure especially if you guys if you hear
oh oh [ __ ] your mom shut up
yeah that's true kids be ripping me on
xbox live dude everyone's [ __ ] my mom
on xbox live yeah you're like what and i
get mad i fight with these kids dude
they call me a [ __ ] online you start
talking [ __ ] back to them i do i do the
opposite i'm like please stop [ __ ] my
mom
i feel like if any if anything should be
a child services alarm it's that [ __ ] i
think that's a good child services but
then we're all going away bro they don't
have enough [ __ ] centers for
everybody though
are you kidding me they even have sting
operations on xbox live to catch some of
these kids that are [ __ ] saying
profanities you guys beating every mom's
cheeks in those days man
every single one of them
it's your heyday yep i was like have you
seen that meme that's been going around
with that girl gamer she was like saying
how like a dude was like oh [ __ ] your
mom or whatever and she's like oh yeah
i'll [ __ ] your dad and give him and give
him a son that he actually loves wow
pro burn girl gamer's [ __ ] doing
their [ __ ] now dude as long as the girl
gamers are sitting there talking about
like
yeah of course you get to talk about
that but like if i bring something out
then it's like everyone's just like
please shut the [ __ ] up rose back girl
yeah just just it's it look you're never
going to solve kids who are watching the
[ __ ] tubes saying whatever the [ __ ]
yeah you'll never solve it ever so what
are you you're going to lecture your way
out of this
you're just feeding the trolls bro
exactly bro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you